brexit is not a fact left versus right
if you hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Frances Foster i'm konstantine kiss
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of watching people having
arguments on the internet of subjects
they know nothing about a trigonometry
we don't pretend to be the experts we
ask the experts
our fantastic guest this week is a
polling expert and one of this country's
leading political scientists Sir John
Curtis welcome to trigonometry thanks
for having me nice to be here
[Music]
it's so good to have you here for anyone
who doesn't know who you are which is
not many people are given that you're on
TV all the time tell us a little about
how are you where you are what's been
your journey through life and what do
you do now well I guess I am best known
for these days for being the public face
for the BBC on election night programs
probably somewhat less known is actually
I've been doing electronic program since
1979 but I spend a lot of time working
on the production side of television
helping to crunch the numbers exactly
without necessary being in front of
cameras so the front of cameras stuff at
least on election nights been had been
been rather more recent how did I end up
there well that's a long story but
basically the person who was my graduate
supervisor when I was doing a PhD was
David Butler now so David Butler who was
the dawn of election television in the
1950s and 1960s he needed somebody in
the 1979 election to sit behind him with
a programmable calculator this is kind
of the early days of computing he didn't
quite want to rely on the BBC computer
and he needed somebody behind him who
could calculate the swing very care
quickly for him when a result came in if
indeed the BBC computer were too fat
while the BBC computer actually didn't
fail on the night but I still got to sit
him behind and then after that actually
somebody else who was also involved in
the bees
operation called Clive Payne persuasions
BBC this is now in 1981 very very early
days of a pc computing and he said look
if we turn up with what in those days
was called a research machines 380 said
which you had to program yourself in
basing I mean you know none of this kind
of software stuff all sitting on your
lap or the oil or your PC or whatever
this is pre PC days but very early small
computers and we turned up and persuaded
the BBC that if they gave us the results
further then Greater London council
election 1981 we could put them through
our sausage machine and we could tell
them about the swings etc etc and then
out of that group grew up and we
persuaded the BBC that actually we could
start doing instant on the night
analysis which then their commentators
could use so that's how it all started
but then beyond that there's obviously
another backstory
that's not my day job it's not my
professional job my professional job is
an academic political scientist but I'm
primarily interested in voting pay for
electoral systems are but also more
generally social and political attitudes
I ended up at Strathclyde basically
because that was one of the two
institutions in the UK which in the
early days of what in political science
we call the behavioural revolution which
is the idea if you're going to study
politics it isn't just about what
politicians do or what constitutions say
but actually it's about trying to
understand how people behave politically
and that also means the focus moves away
from just what happens in Parliament or
in governments or whatever but also to
looking at the general public and stuff
hi and that involves by the way
therefore doing surveys and numbers etc
so I fly together with Essex one of two
places that really embraced this early
on so when I was approached by this
traffic to come on do it
I yeah so that's kind of previously I
was a Liverpool before that I mean back
story be hunt before that the question
be she people I think was a housing you
got involved interested in voting
behavior answer don't
all I can tell you is that my first
political memory is of the death of Hugh
gates school in what 1960 to 1963 and
the Labour leadership election that was
then Howard Wilson then one and remember
being allowed to servant this is what
the age of ten by my or eleven by my
parents to watch the beginning at least
of the 1964 election night resorts
program so by this point somehow at
least I got interested in the horse race
and the fact there were different
political parties there was a degree of
political involvement in my family and
later my mother indeed to become a local
councillor but certainly not active
party politics yes they used to I mean
that used to argue I mean my mother at
least one of her brothers and have
father would argue about politics they
were over there all the different views
what was the split well inland well well
I my my my grandfather was one of the
early activists inside the Labour Party
in Cornwall and his and I think my
mother's brother was there and my mother
was much more liberal party I'm inclined
but you know but they would but anyway
but to be honest there isn't enough
there to explain so somehow now that I
was always interested in this and you
know then went to university and then
went on to do a graduate studies in this
area so that's that's the kind of
fantastic and talking about polling in
numbers in the last two or three years
they've been I can think of one or two
incidents where pollsters haven't
exactly covered themselves in glory yeah
I think that Trump and breaks it might
be good to get examples well I'll
question you what about both of those be
fantastic well question that's the
that's that that makes trigonometry what
is is when we get destroyed by I guess
that's the best normally it's me getting
destroyed let's take it I mean the 2015
general election is an unalloyed
disappointment for the polling industry
because not only did on average all the
polls essentially point towards
conservative level being their connect
with each other but actually they all
did so and there was very little
difference between them and in the air
never got what was
you're conservatives with five six seven
eight points ahead so that was clearly a
wrong call I'll come back to the to the
reasons what the reasons why in a moment
the other examples the people cite are
less obvious so let's take you quoted
Trump well actually bear in mind that on
average the polls of how people were
going to vote in the US preservation had
Hillary Clinton three points ahead she
won by two points in the popular vote
right so don't blame the polls for the
errors of that's the correct word had
the actual college operate so okay
Trump won despite not winning the
popular vote yes we can then argue about
that performance the polls in certain
individual Midwestern states but I can
actually point you to a piece I wrote on
polling day so if I try to keep out of
American politics but eventually
somebody persuading to write something
actually if you look at the polls
carefully enough yeah it looks as though
Hillary Clinton's got about 250 left for
college votes in the back but she hasn't
got 270 she could lose come back to
brexit other one you cited the truth is
if you actually look at all of the
opinion polls that were conducted during
the official four weeks of the campaign
there were slightly more that had lever
head than had remained had what is true
is that in the the last few polls there
was something of a movement back towards
remain although even amongst the final
polls there were two out of the six or
seven or so that had leave ahead but on
average you might have me maemura head
but what was going on there I remember
is that there was a widespread
expectation that the polls would get it
wrong they would get it one because we
all know don't me that what happens in
big constitutional referendums is that
the public drawback at the last minute
from voting from what seems a rather
risky option for change so when the
polls and virtually all the polls the
week before the Pope they brexit my
friend of had leave her head they some
of the men swung back because that all
right we know what's happening it's
obvious that people are swinging back to
remain
or okay well they didn't swing back any
further and actually the poll said we're
a little bit out but in particularly a
few if you had tracked what the polls
that have been done online was saying
ever since September 2016
so I September 2015 from the moment when
we knew what was going to be the
question on the ballot paper the polls
have been done online called it 50/50
from the beginning it remained 50/50 all
the way through and anybody anybody who
thought that it was clear that remain
was going to win were betting against
the polls they were not reflecting what
the polls were saying okay 2017 they're
more complicated
2017 I gained here having underestimated
the conservative performance in 2015 the
polls on average overestimated
conservative performance in 2017 but not
all of them do okay you guys have more
than one exercise one of the exercise is
actually slightly underestimated how
well the consumer is going to do
servation had a poll which again I know
it's a slightly underestimated the
conservative lead but they weren't all
the same count now 2015 and 2017 are
related now one of the things is going
but the simplest story about 2015 is
this is that if you the headline figures
you get out of opinion polls aren't just
simply the number of conservative label
voters except for that the positive
interviewed pollsters appreciate that
trying to interview a relatively but
adequate number of people in a short
period of time is an exercise where at
the end of the day you are going to
struggle to get a wholly representative
sample population so what do they do
well they they're two things they're
doing one is they're going and saying
we're look you know we think you know we
can see that as compared with what we
know about the population in general
this poll is too light on X and one
obvious thing you can do so look hang on
for the purpose of argument only 30% of
our people say they voted labour in the
last election I know the real figure was
34 I need to update the number of labour
voters in our poll perhaps so one things
that they're going on is that they're
there waiting their data demographically
to try and make sure that it's right the
other thing they're doing is say well
hang on I mean some of my people I've
interviewed going to vote some of them
are not I'm not trying to work out who
is and who isn't so they also tried to
take into account the possibility of
differential tennis in other words the
headline figures you get aren't just
simply the unalloyed numbers they're
also then the numbers you get after the
date had been processed well the polls
did a lot of processing in 2015 but not
only was it the case that the headline
number in the polls was conservative
labor even Stevens if you went back to
the original raw data ie before they
done any waiting of filtering or
whatever it was also a dead heat so the
truth is at the end of the day all the
terms they had for weighting and
filtering didn't do anything what was
clear was therefore that the samples
were too Pro labor now why might this be
the case I think this is where life has
got more difficult for pollsters this at
least is part of the explanation one of
the things that's long been true is that
younger people are less likely to turn
out in fact this is almost an iron law
of politics but one of the things that's
changed is that whereas even ten years
ago certainly 15 20 years ago how old
you were was for the most part only
weakly related to your probability of
voting conservative or labour in 2015
this was no longer the case it was
already the case this is pre Corbin that
there are the Labour Party was gaining
ground amongst younger voters and losing
ground Worth Lee speaking amongst older
voters so there were lots of them in
other words the relationship between age
and how people were voting was becoming
more important this therefore meant that
estimating correctly the age difference
in turnout had become more important but
what you can see
from looking the 2015 polls is that
actually they were all under estimating
the age diversity because the problem
then while the problems the polls has if
you're trying to apollon two or three
days is you know and you bring somebody
up or you send something emails thanking
please do my poll if you're interested
in politics you can call gee whiz
fantastic I'll fill in their poll if on
the other hand you're an ordinary same
person they're not terribly interested
in politics you go you know what that's
an offer I could refuse so therefore
whether people donate they tend to get
more of the people who are politically
interested now that's fine in the sense
that what you want to get you're going
to get people to go to the polls but if
along the way the young people in
particular that you interview are
markedly more interested in politics
than other young people and there's then
a relationship between how people vote
and age you're going to trauma so
essentially one of the reasons why the
samples were too poor labor is it yes
the people who may it the young people
who may interviewed in 2015 turned out
to vote and they voted labour the
trouble is they weren't typical of all
young people there were lots of other
young people who didn't turn out to vote
although perhaps they were Labor
inclined and so therefore they're
overestimating neighborhood success so
that's part of the story now 2017 is
this classic case of be careful of
trying to fight the last battle because
ironically if we now redo the same
exercise I said to remember in 2015 look
at the raw unweighted data the polls are
wrong after waiting the polls are just
is wrong the same is not true in 2070 if
in at 2017 you look at the raw
unweighted data in most cases it has the
Conservatives you know moderately ahead
but only moderately ahead the problem
but but no mana and the problem is that
I'm in 2017 the pollsters were doing all
sorts of things to their data to say
look actually I now know that those
young voters not going to turn out and
vote I now know I'm at risk of getting
too many labour voters so they engage in
various strategies which ends up you
know increasing now coming up with a
bigger estimate of the age gap in
turnout of down waiting their labor
and over egging the pudding so they end
up as a result underestimation a
performance not because that's what the
raw data was telling them but because in
trying to correct for that over estimate
of labor support in 2015 they they
basically over compensated for the
problems of 2015 and what their report
in 2017 and ironically you know the
company that in terms of using normally
a poll that got closest to his
observation it's the one company that
decided not to fiddle from what he did
in 2015 so so that's an example of you
know I mean pony has got more difficult
for a variety of reasons and there is no
doubt that this relationship between age
and how people vote and the fact that
then interacts with turnout has made it
more difficult but certainly it's a case
of demonstrating how it is difficult to
get the polynomial because again
anything have to member this and they'll
stop if you if you were commissioning me
as a pollster and you said look I've got
this you're commuting you said I've got
this new comedy show and you were you
were to do a two-minute you know example
of what you're going to do and you say
no go out amongst the public and tell me
you know what proportion of the comedy
market I would get if I were to run a
comedy show like this can you get a
negative proportion on the comedy mark
[Laughter]
you know what if you were to run comedy
shows like that maybe it's a new genre
so yeah you've created a new genre of
comedy show I knew where to say if I
were to create this genre and I work so
to trade market and market it now what
proportion of the comedy industry would
I have and I said to you 30% on the
basis of my market research and two
years later you come back and you say
apart from counting all the money you've
got I've got 25% in the market
you'd probably say I was a pretty good
job right you say actually you told me I
had a marketable product here you told
me how to sell it
gee whiz it worked but if I told you
that you were going to get 30% of the
vote and you only got 25 you'd be deeply
deeply disappointed because we have an
electoral system in the UK that means
that relatively small errors get
magnified when it comes to the outcome
and outside the House of Commons I feel
deeply deeply sorry for pollsters
because isn't this the most difficult
time ever to be a poster where you have
two parties conservative and labor at
the moment and they're hemorrhaging MPs
therefore our emerging support you could
argue they're not really representing
Hulse waves of the population well
they're two things to say that one of
course is to say we've been here before
for those of us who are old enough to
remember the 1980s the fact that a new
party is being created raises exactly
the same polling issues that were raised
from the Social Democratic Party was
first formed in 91
there was a raging debate inside the
polling industry but so how do we best
measure support for this new party
should we just include it in the list of
parties that people can choose among or
do we say to people oh look by the way
you know there's been this new party for
bla bla bla right now how do you think
you might vote in the next election so
in other words do you or do you not
prompt the danger with not prompting is
that people forget that this new pie has
been formed because it's not yet really
in that consciousness and you end up
under estimating their support but the
risk with prompting issue and basically
there's at risk of saying oh by the way
you know there's this new party you know
I mean I'm sure I'm not going to vote
for it it begins to potentially to leave
people and certainly we've already seen
very dramatic differences in the
estimated level of support for the
so-called independent group we've had
polls putting them at five or six not
prompted others putting them at 14 or 18
prompted truth might be somewhere in
between so this
to that extent at least you know this is
an old problem this is my new party's
get formed and particularly very early
on and frankly you know most voters are
not following the soap opera of
Westminster that closely may not even be
following your program John destroys
trigonometry but I'm sure you have a
brilliant and very attentive audience
you know therefore you know it's going
to take a while before actually frankly
you know that the thing is percolating
to the pumpkin and they've and they've
made some sense of it one way or the
other the second point you make about is
different about our political parties
well I mean again I could give you
another long next year but let me give
you the short version I mean what is
undoubtedly true is that brexit has
proven deeply disruptive because the
division between conservative and labor
in our country and and the division that
these two parties are basically
orientated towards discussing and I
relatively comfortable discussing is the
division between left and right so those
on the left are those essentially are
people who think that society is too
unequal and that the government should
be doing something about it
those on the right are those who so look
at the end of the day if we're all going
to be better off we need to create the
incentives for people to take risks and
that therefore means that they have the
end of day some people who successfully
take risks have to be well-paid so you
know that's a continuing arm in our
society about what's the best way to
advance
that's essentially didn't read enough to
write and that is the division that for
the most part at election time you know
if you are right-wing you more like to
vote conservative you're laughing you're
more likely right neighbor
however brexit is not about left versus
right if you are about good versus evil
[Laughter]
this is what
every time both Francis and I voted
remain but we're both quite concerned
about you know democracy being thwarted
and all the rest of it but just to annoy
a lot of my audience every time we
mention the fact that I mentioned the
fact that we voted remain Francis says
because we're good people and then we
get a massive wall of YouTube comments
having a go at us for saying that and
it's not become a joke we're not trying
to pin you down but you're inflicted on
yourself we now have people saying when
are you going to start selling t-shirts
which say which say I voted remain
because I'm a good person
anyway I'm really glad you started
talking about because I was gonna ask
you about left and right it's not a
crucial thing to and it's widely
misunderstood brexit was not about left
versus right we weren't arguing in the e
referendum about the role of the state
in the economy and how to be best in
inequality we were talking about
immigration about sovereignty and what
our relation should be towards a
institutional phenomenon that can be
regarded as an example of the wider
process of globalization alright they
are and whether or not if I ask you a
series of questions about your attitudes
towards inequality and incentives on the
rest of it and I do that it hard it does
not enable me at all to predict whether
you voted remain or leave left wingers
were as likely to vote leave as we're
right wingers okay the division in the
EU referendum was between social
liberals and social conservatives and
this isn't arguments about what it kind
of society you are comfortable living in
on what kind of society you think
Britain should be so a social liberal is
somebody who says look I don't care what
your religion is I your sexual practices
are up to you the market what moral code
you follow is ultimately up to you what
language you speak is up to you whether
or not you salute the Union Jack or what
symbols you decide to adhere to or
respect is up to you I'm
by the way I love living in London it's
a fantastic diverse city so these are
people who are comfortable indeed
embrace the idea of social diversity
they're essentially people with any day
so look it's up to individuals to decide
social and moral code and the religious
code exceptional they live in but at the
other end of the spectrum there's an
argument we might call a social
conservative that says no look at the
end of the day if a society is going to
have at least an adequate degree of
social cohesion then actually society
does need to some degree at least need
to be able to enforce a common moral
code it's a good idea that actually if
we do all have some sense of common
adherence to a set of national symbols
it is a good idea certainly than if we
all speak the same language and of
course also what tends to be true that
people this disposition therefore tend
to be rather uncomfortable with a
diverse environment these are the people
who would echo Nigel Farage's comment
that you know they are uncomfortable
when they cannot hear English being
spoken on a bus these are people of
course who tend to live outside of
London because if you live in London and
you hear English being spoken on the bus
it comes to something of a surprise so
so but there but this is an important
argument about what is the best way of
organizing society now social liberals
voted remain overwhelmingly social
conservatives voted for leave now this
is an element this has always been an
element of our politics it won't
surprise you to hear because the secret
is in the name Liberal Democrats have
always done relatively well amongst
social liberals like by no means get all
the sociable but those who vote Liberal
Democrat are disproportionately social
liberal and now and Liberal Democrats
are more clearly demarcated by those
social liberalism than being on the left
or the right indeed they will be uncut
Party tends to Smither a bit on the
left-right spectrum you know sometimes
things to the left and then swings back
to the right and it swings back to left
again and testicle itself centrist you
Kipp
you keep voters by the way are not
right-wing all those when the UK was
remind blog we're not right-wing Phuket
voters don't like inequality right yeah
that there are the bit where they will
sometimes depart from others is they're
not quite sure they trust the state to
do anything about it but me I remember
you kippers are people who don't like
the way that Britain is going in a whole
variety of ways and it isn't just about
immigration it's also about economic
inequality so you kippers tend to be
left but that's social conservatives so
the thing of a but in what you would
normally have expected in an election
twenty something about brexit when I
expect the Romanians to go to the
Liberal Democrats and you would expect
the social conservatives and the leavers
to go to UK well the the leavers decided
but their best chance was going with the
Conservatives and you can look him was
beginning to look like a busted flush
and there were Democrats still
struggling to recover from the sins as
many people see it of the coalition okay
so the two parties whom you would expect
and indeed during in a much repair
previous period have been articulating
that social liberal social conservative
divide were every week so what happens
the Conservatives lost ground amongst
remainders and gained ground amongst
leave us their vote therefore it become
it was always a bit socially
conservative but their vote becomes more
clearly socially conservative on the
labor side yes lemon party does gain a
grand much slivers but he gains more
ground among stream owners one of things
by the way that I suspect might now just
upset
many of your audience in my view in many
ways Jeremy Corbyn in 2017 achieved what
Tony Blair had been trying to deliver
for years which was to deliver a middle
class social liberal University graduate
vote
Corbin's electorate is much more
obviously Blair right than either the
Blair lights or the Corbin Easter's
would like to believe because Corbin's
was not particularly successful or no
more successful namely about Bernie
getting left-wing voters in his success
was getting in social liberals now but
then the crucial
for what we're then getting we're
getting conservative and labor not only
now having to articulate the left-right
divide with which they are comfortable
but they're now having finding
themselves articulating this social
liberal social conservative device
around 70% of the conservative vote is
socially conservative right - remainer
around 70% of laymen vote is social
liberal and it is because of a lever the
Labour vote is is remainer
and given that there is virtually no
statistical lengthe so the probability
that you are on the left in the way that
I have defined it is more or less
unrelated to whether you are a social
liberal or social conservative right so
we've now got these two dimensions
everything about you've got two
dimensions alright and you're going to
articulate those two dimensions and
they're orthogonal to each other that
might angles to each other you really
need four parties yes yeah but it's been
articulated by two so conservative
labour are both being deeply disrupted
because they are now finding themselves
tackling an issue which is not a
left-right issue it's an issue that took
two different set of values a certain
values that they are not at heart of
what they are about but which is deeply
disruptive of their normal electoral
coalition's and therefore they are
struggling to deal with the issue as
well as the fact they're also deeply
polarized by brexit so that's the sense
in which the party so the irony is that
the success of the pot you know 2017 was
this election in which ironically the
level of support for conservative and
labour combined was higher than had been
in election since 1970 but underneath
that edifice was the fact that the the
base of their vote created both parties
really serious problems and you know
anything the most obvious way it comes
out is this at the end we tend to think
of the Conservative Party as being a
party that promotes the interests of big
business but the electorate that the
Conservative Party has gained is a
protectionist election it's a lecture
that is looking for some shelter from
the winds of globalization the very
globalization process that big business
thinks is helping it to put to it to you
know achieve better things and to
positive so there's now so the the
problem for this are the concerned
parties of this tension between its
traditional backers and the nature was
naturally was see that you know you know
you know get conservative is how is it
that my party is doing these things it's
so bad for big business but that's the
tension its face the tension on the
labor side is although the Labour Party
these days is pretty much is almost as
popular amongst university graduates as
it is amongst those in working-class
occupations the Labour Party still
thinks of itself as a party that
represents the working-class and of
course it's more working-class and it's
more of it's wrote that tended to vote
leave
so you've therefore got this attachment
to the more working-class end of its
vote because that's part of the stoical
mission it's the people who they think
that they represent and therefore there
perhaps is a greater concern about the
consequences of upsetting that section
of his vote even though it's very
clearly a minority of his vote dan would
otherwise be the case so you can see how
the brexit divide cuts across the
parties traditional conceptions of
themselves and who they think of as
being their traditional allies and
kolben and the Labour Party have sort of
turned their back almost on the levers
who voted for them by saying that they
could embrace I think is it a second
referendum and it all that's a much
that's far too simple a articulation of
whether the Labour Party position is
essentially that if and only if Theresa
May can get her deal through the House
of Commons and the House of Lords she
then has to pass a second hurdle which
it needs to win a referendum where
remain would be the option the Labour
Party has not committed itself to being
in favor of a referendum should we get
precipitated into an early June election
it's still reserved its position on that
and it also isn't saying that we are
therefore willing to allow Teresa may's
deal to go through the House of Commons
so it's it's it's a limited move it's a
move that I certainly indeed the party
has felt it had to make because you know
about 60% of labour voters are in favor
of a secondary referendum and that at
the end of the day is that you know is
that is the bigger end of its
constituency but it's not gone so far as
to come out on an unalloyed fashion and
there's a group particularly a crucial
difference between what the Labour Party
is proposing and what Peter Karl and his
colleague Wilson we're proposing so that
there I think was a very adroit attempt
to move the debate on to that so the car
wilson at least as originally drafted
we'll wait and see what comes out next
week was you know what we'll let Theresa
Mays deal go through the house comments
so that she can have the chance to put
her vote
ideal to the public and I think that's
much better Polly I'm pretty critical of
the people's vote campaign because the
people's vote campaign has been so much
framed in terms of that people will lie
to all these false claims they now know
what about what it's about
oh and by the way the opinion polls tell
us that there remain on our head
ergo therefore we should have a
referendum it's not an argument that is
ever going to persuade leave out is that
perhaps we should have another
referendum whereas what once you were in
the car Wilson referendum my proposal
it's much more politically a joy it's
saying to leave voters yeah she's
struggling to get it through the House
of Commons yeah you don't trust the
house Commons do you a punt is this is
the establishment ganging up on the
leave program we are willing to put it
back to you
you decide and I think Whigs ago though
the
it was clear that resumes deal was in
trouble
the people's vote campaign should have
moved on and they should have tried to
reach out to those on the lee side but
the trouble is those involved in the
people's vote campaign I think are so
much the committed remain as that I
think the ideological vitchard has
blinkered to them to what would have
been the politically astute move I mean
not least because at the end of the day
if you're going to get a second
referendum persuading labor was one of
the steps but almost turned out is not a
sufficient step above all you need to
persuade sections of the conservative
you need particularly pope to persuade
that middle rump of the conservative
party which will vote for tourism Mays
deal but certainly won't vote for No
Deal
I know desperate for a kind of for us to
get out of all of this and that this is
this is the way out but you're not going
to persuade them by MIT by a set of
proposals that just look like an attempt
to reverse brexit so that's like reach
out and persuade yeah we don't seem to
be doing much of that these days it
seems to me like it's more that we've
split into two extremes and what worries
me and we talked about it before we
started the show was what happens in
several eventualities that are possible
we have the No Deal such as we leave on
WTO jobs we have teresa's may deal yeah
let's say that goes or we have
essentially breaks it's watered and
doesn't happen yeah now my extension or
potentially extension and then and then
we go back to the original yeah doesn't
know happen happen happens happens under
some kind of deal yeah now as I look at
all three of those scenarios and then I
look at what I perceived to be the mood
in the country which is going to be a
lot less accurate than what you perceive
but nonetheless if we look at all of
that I can see in all three of those
scenarios a very significant group of
people who are going to be deeply deeply
unhappy about what's happened yeah what
do you think our other is the future of
this country in those three scenarios
how the different I mean I think the
first thing to say is I think whatever
we do we are going to upset
there is no easy way out of where we
find ourselves because we are
essentially polarized web yeah we are
polarized between ace at least up you
know somewhere between a half and
two-thirds of leave voters would at the
end of the day and they either say
leaving without a deal is what I would
most like to happen or they say in some
cases I'm that's what I'm willing to do
okay
around two-thirds of remain errs go
I want another referendum and around
three-quarters of remainders when they
want to referendum or not at least still
say you know we despite all the other
choices around I'm definitely a
remainder and most of them say that they
would vote the same way so we are we are
deeply polarized and one of the
difficulties about brexit is that you
know we often talk about how supposedly
what politicians should do is to search
for the center ground the problem with
but that's based on the assumption is
based on the assumption that basically
to use the jargon the distribution of
attitudes in our society is uni-modal ie
there are lots of people in the middle
lots of people who lost there are lots
of people it's everything of it being
our you know just a left-right debate
for the moment that most people are in
the middle they're neither very
left-wing nor very right-wing their
centrist
okay and there aren't very many people
on the extreme left and the extreme
right and the point is that if you are
therefore trying to win election the
argument is you therefore need to go
towards the center because that's where
most voters are you might be set to
right start to left but you need to be
in the center
the trouble with brexit is in my view is
the distributions completely different
it's it's u-shaped right so there are
lots of people on what we might want to
call the extreme leave end of the
spectrum there are lots of people and
what we might want to call the extreme
remain end of the spectrum and there
aren't that many people in the middle me
in Francis well wherever you find
yourselves if you're in the middle
you're on alone you
yeah and you see this I mean so the
irony of what's been going on I think is
that both Theresa May and Jeremy Corbyn
in their ways have been trying to find a
break sitcom but not least because of
the reasons I'm anything about how
brexit divides to their parties and
calls them such attention you know
Theresa Mayes compromise which is what
her deal tries to encapsulate is well
I've got certain fixed lines I think we
have to get out of freedom movement
because of the concerns about
immigration where we've only got out the
open court of justice because the
concerns about sovereignty and we should
be able to make our own train deals
which again is partly about sovereignty
in a part in argument about whether or
not the EU is or isn't a protectionist
organisation which is a very very long
running debate but then within within
those red lines which is the kind of the
kernel of the leaf case however we then
in need I think what was the phrase as
frictionless the relationship with the u
EU as possible so then she's buying into
the remaining argument though we do
still need to have a closer trading
relationship within you because it's
still fifty five percent of our external
trend so that's her compromise
jeremy corbyn's compromise is a softer
brexit than hers it's you know Norway
plus my what it's it's single market -
but with customs union added so it's a
kind of variant of Norway but it's you
know Corbin's rhetoric is we need to
bring together the 52% who voted remain
and the 42% of motor leave and we think
the somebody don't so we're
acknowledging the concerns about freedom
freedom of movement
We certainly have concerns about the
limitations on the state aid rules of
the of the European Union but you know
we need to have it we need to have a
close relationship now boats and they're
both compromises okay the trouble is
what you discover is that when you ask
people to choose either between mrs.
Mayes deal and remain and no deal
you find that mrs. Mays deal is the
least popular of the three options but
it's also the case if you ask people to
choose between remain what we were
purposes a shorthand call Norway which
is roughly where labor our heart and no
deal Norway is third
and although it's true that you can you
can argue that around 1/2 of the public
would be willing to accept a kind of
labor party type soft brexit and we
suspect that there's a majority for that
in the House of Commons the trouble is
it's a remainder project soft practice
of the kind the Labour Party is talking
about although it was designed to try to
bridge the divide between remain and
leave at the end of the day is something
that remainders might be willing to buy
into because it's now it's a soft brexit
it's levers are reluctant to buy into it
so it's very very difficult to find the
compromise that will satisfy people so
yes you're right the problem we then
faces this if we leave without a deal a
lot of people will be deeply upset
alright so there's already substantial I
believe voters will go yippee but the
clear majority of the public around -
and maybe as much as two-thirds of the
public will be at least unhappy in some
cases will be deeply deeply upset and
what kind of sales are really gonna fall
I mean sure anybody knew anything about
the food and industry would have known
the 29th of March was the worst time for
this country to potentially be cut off
from its ooh food supplies it's the
lowest level of food availability from
domestic sources but anyway yeah but
equally if we go for a second referendum
given at least the nature of the support
for it as I have described that also is
going to set a lot of people upset a lot
of people so can one say can one
criticize the idea of a second
referendum on the grounds
it'll be deeply divisive yes
but can one do come on also criticize
the idea of living without a deals being
deeply divisive also yes yeah so both
the things which are the two most
popular options are potentially you know
the different devices but the difference
there is that people voted to leave
right people didn't vote to have a row
second referendum that's the difference
between those things that's true but the
problem you have is that although a
substantial body of leave voters voted
for no deal there is a substantial
minority of leave voters who are opposed
to the idea and you put them with remain
voters and it's clearly not obviously
yeah
yeah yeah absolutely now why have you
kick therefore collapse shouldn't be
there shouldn't this be the most fertile
rich point and UKIP's history where they
come in they go to Tories libbed
will not live them settle in anyway and
yeah and they'll bring them all in no
it's toys so yeah part of the history ok
one of the reasons why Teresa may
mayor's deal this is unpopular city is
that particularly starting with the
checkers agreement of last summer
support for her and her deal fell
particularly everybody voters so I
problem now is that leave voters were
almost as likely to oppose their dealers
remain voters but she's she lost the
confidence of leave voters during the
course of the brexit negotiations
checkers was a crucial moment and then
the unveiling of the deal itself in
mid-november saw support for her
position fall even further amongst new
voters so you know that's the problem
that she finds herself in which is she
it isn't obvious that those who voted
leave actually back the idea that she's
in favor of but I mean they only did
bear in mind is this you know let's say
how deal go so we could therefore say we
can say well no deal divisive EU
referendum divisive well let's take the
least worst option of the thing that's
on the table and let's just let the deal
through bear at bear in mind that's not
going to stop the argument we have
barely started the argument because all
we will do if we were to let the deal go
through is to mean that the withdrawal
treaty becomes legal force what does the
withdrawal treaty do it protects the
rights of EU citizens it commits the UK
to paying roughly thirty nine billion
quid for the next two or three years and
to renew coffers and it's got the
provisions about the so-called northern
own and backstop to try to avoid any
risk either having to be a border
between the north and the south of our
nothing else we've not talked about
whether what I mean the pijl declaration
says the UK doesn't want to be in
freedom of movement and we recognize
that but the Buga declaration is
privileged
it's not how much how close in
relationship the UK has will depend on
what rules the UK is willing to follow
now if it's not running through freedom
movement it won't be a to be in the
single market and if it's not wanting to
follow ucj rules and be in the customs
union and certainly it's sorry that will
so limit its options but beyond that it
doesn't say any we for it doesn't settle
those basic things like European health
cards mobile phone calls what actually
would be that what relationship with the
single market we have what regulations
we're going to follow etc etc and we're
going to carry on arguing for at least
another two years until the end of
transition period may well be longer and
for example I fast forward for you it is
October 2020 somehow or you know the
government we still got the current
government somehow another Teresa may
has got deals gone through we now have a
new deal maybe not negotiated by Teresa
may maybe she resigned after the shortly
after the end of it we left the European
Union and the Prime Minister is
struggling to get his or her deal
through the House of Commons because
they don't like the new proposed treaty
on our relationship with the European we
could go through the whole of this cycle
again because at that point we will be
defining many of the things about our
future relationship at the moment people
are worried about so why are people
concerned about the northern backstop
more the essential reason I think is
because it potentially constrains the
free trade deal that we can have it
pushes it pushes us towards having a
closer relationship than some brexit
ears would like but we've not had this
argument so look forward to more and
more so the fit so frankly even if mrs.
Mays deal goes through well a it's going
to go through grudgingly but it still be
divisive customers still going to be
arguing about whether or not we should
be coming out of freedom movement what
are the consequences et cetera et cetera
this is going to be a very long running
story there is no avoidance of division
on brexit because its buffet resolving
brexit is a very very difficult issue do
you think was a mistake
well I understand why it happened put it
like this it was I mean I will say two
things
I mean at the end of the day it's very
difficult to sustain a set of political
arrangements which basically by which I
mean giving people authority to make the
law of the land all right it's very
difficult so this is a question about
whether it's very difficult to continue
to maintain a set of arrangements that
says institution X has the authority to
determine the law for this bit of
territory it's very difficult to do that
and continue with those arrangements if
the people to whom the law applies do
not regard that institution as being a
legitimate source of authority you know
we had this debate in Scotland in 2014
about whether or not it was legitimate
for the United Kingdom to be able to
make the law for Scotland or not and
again the argument here certainly today
is it you know is it legitimate for the
European Union to be able to make some
of the law for the United Kingdom
because we are showing out you know
showing us already
I mean and the fundamental failure of
the European project in this country in
my view is that it failed to instill in
the UK population the sense that we are
European and at the end of the day what
tends to underpin a willingness to share
a set of political institutions is a
common sense of identity so why you know
albeit with some considerable fraying at
the edges in Scotland in Northern
Ireland for the most part the majority
of the population in the UK accept the
authority of Parliament and government
exception well because in part we feel
British so we're all us okay
the problem for the European project in
this country is the only around one in
eight of us also feel European
Europe is other and therefore it was
always impossible for basically to use
it the simple colloquial ingre why are
Brussels bossing us about because
Brussels is not us it's that funny place
on the other side of the English Channel
of which we do not feel part the you
they are the Europeans we are the Brits
all right so that's the fundamental
issue I don't in now you can look at the
European Union's own Eurobarometer data
and we are the only country together
with Greece where a majority of the
population are means deny deny that they
are European okay so that's so the truth
is you know we've never been more than
so many touch members of the European
Union we've been in it for what we could
get out of it and when during the last
10 or 20 years we have experienced by
our own historical standards very high
levels of net inward migration and the
brutal truth is that with freedom of
movement you cannot control immigration
this presented a potential problem of
judoma see so now that's the big answer
to now there's the small answer to you
which is why the David Cameron got his
tactics wall almost undoubtedly wrong I
mean insofar as what David Cameron was
trying to do was to kill the issue in
two senses his first name went in with
the so-called Bloomberg speech in
Germany 2013 which is what set this
whole process enjoy his immediate aim
was my gosh Nigel Farage and you keep
support has gone up our support has gone
down it was the first time that the
conservative end of the coalition had
been in political trouble this is the
time of omni shambles etc etc and he
wanted to kill the UK challenge so what
does he do he takes UK policy we have a
referendum but he does so in the
expectation that he's never going to
have to deliver because he's in
coalition with the Liberal Democrats who
certainly are willing to have a
referendum on our on our membership at
the moment and who were always blocking
any attempts to pass one after Cameron's
promise etc etc and Cameron probably did
not expect to get
for majority in 2015 okay so so in the
end it failed to scupper you Kip
in the short one at least only after the
referendum ironically he then he then
found himself with a promise he hadn't
expected to come to to deliver I know I
think he then made a third mistake and
the third mistake from his point of view
was that he rushed Artic too quickly he
was clearly wanting to move on he had a
substantial domestic agenda he wanted to
pursue
he's already time limited his
Premiership has been being about 2019
2020 he told us we were he wasn't going
to go for another term
why he should and what you know he was I
expect him to be able to do hard work I
mean he's doing exciting the same thing
at Howard Wilson did in 74 75 hard
Wilson became prime minister on a
promise to hold a referendum on our
membership of the then Common Market
after he'd renegotiated the terms of our
membership now Wilson pulled it off he
came back from the country in March 1975
and said I've renegotiated our terms of
Merit he was all fine and dandy public
opinion swung around and we voted
two-to-one to stay inside the Common
Market Cameron didn't succeed in pulling
off the same trick he wasn't given
enough by the opinion but what he should
have been when he been willing to do is
he and he done this before to great
theatrical effect he should have been
willing to play it much longer he should
have been willing to walk out of a
European Council and go they're not
giving me what I want this is not good
enough the negotiations have broken down
and to play long and the point war would
have been that if he had made it if he'd
apparently been more determined
I'm parently more robust with the
European Union he might have been in
that in a better position to turn it
around but then and then of course
putting in time and then the other
I guess final mistake he made was you
know he was the last person to go around
saying if we leave the European Union
the world will collapse tomorrow because
this was somebody whose political record
was hours a Euroskeptic he had said that
if negotiations didn't go well he'd been
willing to argue in favor
leaving and he failed to appreciate that
once see the cat European Council it not
turn public opinion around and above all
had not turned his party around that he
was no longer Prime Minister he was
leader of the Opposition and that he was
dependent on the opposition ie the
Labour Party to get himself out of the
jam but did he talk to Lord Mandelson or
many another ardent remainer about how
the campaign should be fought no they
mistakenly run misunderstood what they
had done in Scotland has been a success
of fighting essentially a negative
campaign about the economic consequences
it was not a success in Scotland it was
a failure and he did not work this time
so the lots and lots of tactical
mistakes and including you know it
didn't G was original objective it was a
promise that you know be careful what
you promise because sometimes your
promises you have to deliver even though
you don't expect to do so and then
having found himself hoisted on his own
petard I think then he did not pay
enough attention to actually from his
perspective plays in such a way that
might have increased his chances of
actually getting remain vote those
tactical issues aside though and we've
got time for maybe one or two more
questions those tactical issues aside
from what you're saying about our
cultural attitudes towards Europe and
how we feel about ourselves in this
country yeah it seems almost inevitable
that we would come to a point where the
issue of our membership of the EU would
come to the fore given that we don't
really feel European and as you say the
levels of immigration that we've seen in
this country over the last 20 years sure
yeah sure I mean yeah I mean the I mean
the issue of our membership of the
European Union has kept on being an
issue ever since 1975 alright you know
not long after the referendum in 1975
that ever the Labour Party particular
from 1979 came out in favor of us
leaving the European Union there was
then a narrow period in the late 80s and
early 90s when both pinnacle parties
were strongly in favor after Labor Party
changed its mind but then once in a post
Maastricht and the fall of Margaret
Thatcher the euros gets increase inside
the Conservative Party and again you
know we be sure we've long been on
in our uncertain and yes I mean at the
end there I mean the difficulty for the
remains side was yes it's partly about
immigration and the fact that you know
indeed immigration had been high that
you know in 2000 it in 2004 we were the
most Pro euro file country along with
Sweden in Ireland we gave the citizens
of then so-called AAA countries are
Poland Czech Republic etc the immediate
freedom of movement wide cinematography
I want to come here who want you to come
to this wet miserable dark cloudy
country you know it's us who want to go
to live by the Mediterranean no of
course they came and the Polish problem
became you know anything such cetera
and then of course in 2010 Cameron said
he was going to get net migration down
to less hundred thousand even never got
anywhere now so there's that sense of
fair so that's one of the problems the
other problem however is is of course is
also the fallout from the financial
crash in the eurozone crisis back in 20
1975 it was very very easy to argue why
the UK should remain as it was only just
recently joined the then common market
it was the six original members of the
common market have enjoyed much higher
and much more sustained levels of
economic growth than we have we have
been the sick man of Europe you know as
soon as we turn on the taps of probably
expanding inflation goes up as soon as
we turn them off again unemployment goes
up and this stop-go economy well by 2016
rather than being portrayed as an
unalloyed economic success the European
Union's economic credentials worship at
least shall we say more debatable and
the eurozone
I had crisis I've been dealt with raise
questions about you know its
effectiveness as an organ as an economic
organization and although this country
did take a pretty big hit in 2008 it was
certainly coming out of the financial
crash much more quickly than
particularly many a southern european
european union member
ergo the economic case was more
difficult so yeah so given that our
relation was always a transactional one
economic argument more problematic the
immigration argued body was never there
in 1975 now and then you've still then
got the contend that those who never
ever accepted the idea that should be in
the European in the first place put all
that together and yes it becomes
problematic and how much of do you think
that that vote was a rebellion which is
what people have classed as as a working
class people giving two fingers up to
Cameron and the ruling elite as it were
I think I mean I sit it's fair to say
that certainly a populist narrative is
also part of the mix you know the idea
certainly that you know that there's an
elite out there which is running things
are great against our interest I
wouldn't use the language of class I
would use the language of educational
background but certainly you know again
if you you know listen to leave
discourse it's about how the true that
the interests of ordinary people are
being you know commandeered are being
distorted by you know the liberal
establishment who tend to be university
graduates who've had this wonderful
liberal education the rest of us have
paid for etcetera etc so there's the
sense of being justly I'm being
distorted not only by the state but also
it's distorted by those in in big
business you know that's certainly part
of the sentiment but it's then but I
would then say you know it's that
sentiment together with a socially
conservative discourse you know and a
concern about sovereignty it's it's all
those things together but yes given that
we are talking about a situation in
which no we are having I thinking behind
all of this this we are having a debate
about the process of globalization at
the end of the day you know you know one
ways about thinking about is this um
I've you know earlier I described the
argument as being about immigration and
about social liberals and social
conservatives partly being as being a
cultural one but it's also an economic
one at the end of the day if you are a
university graduate with particularly
forgotten linguistic qualification or
you've got a professional qualification
freedom of movement is an opportunity if
on the other hand you are an older
person you have little in the way of
labor market skills immigration is
something that happens to young people
from elsewhere
come to your neighborhood a neighborhood
which perhaps is not previously had much
experience of net inward migration and
what's the advantage to you so there's
that and then of course is then there's
the broader argument about globalization
more hang on living standards for most
people have not been increasing indeed
in some cases they've been declining
although overall levels of inequality
have not necessarily increased we've
certainly not managed to reverse the
sharp increase in equality that occurred
in the 1970s and 1980s and at the very
top of the income spectrum at least you
know that there are their arguments to
be hard so against against the back of
all of that yes you can see how a focus
on this institution whose legitimacy was
always questionable which seems to be
our ticket it seems to be promoting the
forces of globalization that don't seem
to be doing is some of us much good and
for MOOCs frankly we'd like a bit of
protection both economically and
culturally how that mix does help to
bring about the mood that we have well
we have time for one final question
which is the question we always ask
which is what is the one thing that
we're not talking about as a society
that we ought to be talking about well
this is still gonna be about brexit but
we've spent the last hour or so talking
about remainders and about leaving yeah
but if we were to have another
referendum at the moment it looks as
though the crucial group could be those
who did not vote in June 2016 so we do
not support any remain let's think this
leavers think this well 30% of the
population didn't vote in 2016
some of them and
there are now people who were 16 and 17
in 2016 who now could vote and insofar
as the polling data does suggest that
maybe we would get a small majority in
favor of remain second time around if
there were a second time around the
reason for that is not essentially
because those who voted two years ago
changed their minds but rather that
those who didn't vote two years ago now
seem to have made up their minds rather
late in the day but they are at least 2
to 1 in favor of remains so the story of
those who did not vote 2 years ago might
be perhaps the most important story
about the Bexar process and insofar as
now we can perhaps critically evaluate
the rhetoric about the people have
spoken therefore they will have to be
implemented well almost in in although
the turnout was high by standards of
recent general elections at the end of
the day there was no substantial body
people who did not vote and the outcome
was close only in every in those
circumstances you can always go around
and ask well is it still the will of
people now well maybe the world won't
find out certainly the one thing it's
easier to say that the world of people
is definitely to leave it much clearer
thing is the people are divided glad
we've solved it thank you very much for
coming on the show are you mentioned
twitter are you on twitter do you use e
so I have to institutional accounts so I
have out what UK thinks in which I
promote and occasionally comment on
attitudes towards brexit and I also have
an account called what what Scots think
which is about public attitudes towards
the constitutional debate in Scotland
and they're associated with two websites
that follow these two stories
I also saw there's a Twitter account
which which is called something like Sir
John on TV indeed there is a spoof
account where the story behind that's
very I think I never said is that on the
18th of April 2017 which is the day that
Theresa May announced the 2017 general
election I was sitting quietly in an
office in Edinburgh where I work one day
week it was the Tuesday after Easter
think only a nice quiet day and get on
with things their phone and I get rung
up by the news channel BBC and they say
the Prime Minister's about to make an
announcement um we're not quite sure
what it is not sure by the change he's
ill and she's resigning or what but
maybe there's going to be an election so
I said I tell you what get me a car I'll
go down to the BBC studio in Edinburgh
and if it's about something out so I'll
just quietly go away and if it is
general action I'll be there walk was
this by General action you know three
hours broadcasting later money's just
about to escape an order could pick up
my belongings somewhere I'd left them
come back he gained you about another
word twice a broadcast you know I think
there probably was a non and substantial
body of people at least somebody on
Twitter one why a TV all the time well I
just happened to be in the wrong place
at the wrong time but I think that's
when it started and then it's kind of
wrong you know it's kind of mushroomed
after that but to give you some idea of
how we cherchez this group of people can
sometimes be I'm certainly aware that on
one occasion I think it was just after
the 27x I did something for Flemish
fantastic and we are as always a trigger
pod and all the social media subscribe
to the YouTube channel click the bell
button next to subscribe button and give
us a review on iTunes we will see you in
a week from now with another brilliant
episode thanks guys see you next week
[Music]